hi how's it going
so I'm making this video today just have
a wee chat I'm not chat is to do with
notifications yay fun so I did a live
stream yesterday I don't know how many
people know about it because there was
it was a comment left on underneath the
recording of the live stream and that
person said you streamed this I had no
idea I received no notification okay so
I figured it was appropriate to make
this video in case anybody else is
wondering why they're not saying stuff
if you go to my channel and when you
click Subscribe hopefully if you click
Subscribe you'll see a little bail to
the right-hand side of the subscription
button if you click that you will
receive all notifications excuse me
you'll receive all notifications so
it'll turn from a bail to bail it looks
like it's ringing
another thing is for some reason even
though I can't believe the fetters have
got they monetized but even though I'm
censoring the swearing which I thought
would help my last plays are still
getting flagged and partially D
monetized I don't know I guess I'm just
not gonna censor myself anymore
you went everyone because the only other
thing I can think of as the the content
of the game is deemed violent so it's
getting D monetized I can request the
manual review but I don't know if that
will work and I don't know if there's
any repercussions to requests in a
manual review and I'm still rejecting it
well there I'll get my channel striked
or whatever
it's stressful times at the minute so go
away you can help my channel for free is
to turn on notifications and watch my
videos at least because I really am
trying to amp up production
I mean you've probably seen hopefully
again the notification thing but
hopefully you've seen over the past two
weeks I've really been trying to make
quality content as I can but also as
much as I can I'm pretty much trained
that's like a full-time job at the
minute I'm hoping to grow my channel I
have a lot of projects in the pipeline
if you've noticed with a few exceptions
all of the SCP documents that I'm doing
are part of the Heritage Collection on
the SCP wiki which is like you know the
original kind of scps that are like the
most famous I'm doing that complete
collection to start off with I kind of
like doing things in collections it's
kind of my thing like this collection
that collection for example Lombardi
tales was a collection the heels of mr.
collector and as a collection I plan on
finishing not by the way but I've also
got projects yet to come out and they're
still in their early stages one of them
is the D classes mind one I'm not sure
I'm gonna call it the classes mind but
it'll be the same concept as Freeman's
mind if you're not familiar with that
google it because it'll be kind of the
same except with SCP containment breach
because I've voiced the main character
of containment breach I thought it would
be cool to try and do that maybe some
people would like though and then lastly
there scp-049 FAQ which is which is
which is a hard one the voice find
questions find Gabriel Jade root them if
you don't know that's the author of
scp-049
but the final thing that I have to get
done is the visuals they are really
really hard to do for somebody like me
I'm figuring source filmmaker as I go
whereas some D like uh Pat stop videos
he has like millions and millions of
fans I don't know how I'm gonna make it
as good as hers but ahem that's in the
pipeline as well but I am the Harvard ID
at Christmas I'm gonna am okay good
evening wow this is been going on for a
long time this video clearly you're
somebody who cares about my channel but
if you stuck it out this long so the
point of this video was if you enable
notifications you'll see all my videos
that I post I'm really trying to make
the video the SCP document reads more
entertaining than my competition so if
you like them share them I really don't
ask for this
I really haven't asked for this much in
the past but if you like them share them
because I put so much effort into them
the visualizers and everything I know a
lot of people said they weren't very
important but I think it looks cool I
think it's worth doing for new people
getting into the foundation it gives
them something to look at and read along
with me anyway god I digress I really
can't string a coherent thought together
on on camera so so enable notifications
I thought that's it actually the rest
was just a tangent yeah okay thank you
very much for listening and I'll see you
later bye
you